did you ever buy something that seemed
like a good idea at the time but then
you ended up having to buy
more accessories and now having to
maintain it so you ended up with
less time and more clutter or do you
ever spend time
trying to figure out where your stuff is
to begin with in this video i'm going to
share with you
five areas that you can simplify in your
home by decluttering the excess
and today we're going to talk about two
specific kinds of clutter
number one the items that haven't been
used in months or even years because
chances are if they haven't been used
in a while they probably will not be
used again
and number two items that can be
condensed into what is functional or
necessary
or even that of which you believe to be
beautiful or a value but i'll explain
that as we go along
first follow me to my office you may or
may not have an office but chances are
you have a stack of papers that need
organizing
or you have random office supplies that
haven't been used and
who knows how long the office is
supposed to be where we're most
productive and creative but
how can we be creative when we're
drowning in papers
or we can't even find them to begin with
my first tip for going through the
office is
first going through every single item
for important papers that you don't
necessarily want to keep but you have to
keep such as receipts or tax records
i would recommend saving the hassle of
having to look through them or to find
them
by saving them electronically this is
actually something that i have done with
our company information
i took one whole day to take all of our
boxes of paperwork
to scan them into our computer and maybe
i'm a little paranoid but i saved it
onto my computer and two separate flash
drives saved in
two separate safes just in case you
never know
there are of course different programs
and apps now that you can use to store
your information so you don't have to do
it that particular way
but the main thing is to get rid of the
physical paperwork so that you save time
looking for them you save space and you
gain more clarity because you're not
drowning
in all this paperwork you can actually
have a clear open space to work in
please excuse my lighting it is 5 am as
i'm filming this so this is what i have
to work with
but typically what i have on my desk at
any given time
is a clock because i like to avoid
looking at my phone
when i'm working on something it's just
a distraction the current book that i'm
reading and a notebook
and then i have a little scripture verse
of course my computer
my speaker for youtube videos
and of course my printer and then on
this
cabinet is basically all of my office
supplies now everything that you might
need is
could be totally different but i have
some notebooks
this here is what i have limited myself
to as far as pens and pencils so i
had this just this old container and i
realized i did not need
a hundred different kinds of pens and
pencils and highlighters
so i limited myself to only this this
whatever fits in here
so in continuing to talk about office
supplies in general
i used to have a giant collection of
pens and pencils and highlighters
but for me i didn't need to have that
many
so look through the kinds of items that
you have and first of all check to make
sure that these pens even work because
they might not even work
but rather than having a specific number
of amount that you should have for any
kind of office supply
ask yourself how many you really need
for example you might be an artist so
you might need a lot of different
colored pencils
and supplies such as those for me i
don't do that particular work so i just
need just a few and this is probably a
little bit too much
next go through those items that you
haven't used in a while for example
six months to a year for me i had a
paper cutter
that i bought about four years ago and i
had used it like maybe three times since
then
that was clutter i did not need that and
for sentimental items such as
artwork that you or your kids have done
save these for last
if you can be happy without them and you
don't need them then
by all means declutter them but if
you're still kind of on the fence then
maybe one thing you can consider is
taking
pictures of these items instead that way
you keep the memory
but you don't keep the physical clutter
okay
i'm getting hungry how about we go to
the kitchen dinnerware is the next area
that we will cover and this includes
cups mugs plates and tupperware they say
the kitchen is the heart of the home
and a lot of us do spend a lot of time
in the kitchen i know personally with a
toddler i
certainly do and when i used to live
with my parents nothing used to annoy me
more than being in a rush to go to
school
opening the cabinet doors only to have
an avalanche of tupperware fall all over
me
or spend 10 minutes trying to find one
darn lid that would fit
any of those containers since we
decluttered our kitchen we've not only
been able to save time so we're not
spending 10 minutes looking for a lid
but it actually looks more appealing so
i'm not afraid if guests come over and i
open the cabinet doors
so let me show you our dinnerware
everything that we have in these
floating shelves and these cabinets is
basically all that we have for
dinnerware and then maybe just a few
that we're currently using
and yes i do have quite a lot of place
for just a family of three
soon to be four but for me it's
important to have extra
dinner plates and cups for when we have
visitors over because it saves a lot of
money and it saves the environment from
having to constantly be buying
disposable so one thing you will notice
is that a lot of these
items like the tupperware there these um
containers that we save from my
husband's favorite yogurts
the cups here and the plates stack very
well when we moved here i specifically
purchased items that would stack well
because we don't have a lot of cabinet
space
so this helps us to reduce clutter and
it saves a lot of precious space
also you will notice that i have a lot
of stainless steel cups and mason jars
i like these kinds of items because
they're very versatile they work for a
lot of different purposes
like mason jars can be used for drinking
they can be used for storing sauces
for storing berries yogurts meal
prepping oatmeal
even flower vases they probably have a
bajillion ways to be used
i also purchased these stainless steel
cups specifically because they stack so
well
and again we don't have a lot of cabinet
space so that is
a huge must for us but also they can be
used for hot and cold items
so we were able to toss our wine glasses
and use these instead
if you're interested in cups like these
i can include the link in the
description for these
so couple tips is you can have stackable
items to save space
have items that are versatile that you
can use for multiple purposes
but you'll also notice that i don't have
any souvenir cups holiday mugs or random
dinner plates
except for my blue cups it's all the
same color pretty much white
i did that intentionally to limit visual
clutter as well
so if you can try to stick with neutral
colors or just matching colors in
general
and do away with all of the holiday
decor souvenir cups and mugs and all
that kind of stuff
my tupperware is not eco-friendly it is
plastic but i've had it for about five
years now
the main thing that i would suggest to
you though is to find
one particular kind or brand that stacks
well
that way you're not having to look for
different kinds of lids for different
tupperwares and wasting so much time
so much clutter that's just crowding
your space
the next area of the home that a lot of
us could use a major declutter in
is probably the bathroom when i left
with my parents they had a huge
assortment of personal care items and
when they finally let me declutter it
i found items there from years ago that
had been expired
i bet you they had no idea that these
things were even there so go through
your bathroom and look through
every single item this part is important
so what you can do is remove
the cabinets and pour out all of the
items that are in there and go through
each of them one by one
look for these particular items expired
items
unused items from who knows when those
hotel freebies that you never used up
because why they're just collecting
space anyway
and if you have a favorite lotion or
perfume or just any kind of personal
care
product for example then you can
probably ditch all of the rest because
why have five different kinds if you
keep coming back to just one
i used to be notorious for having 10
different kinds of lipsticks but only
using one and rarely ever using the rest
so think of items like these for you and
get rid of those kinds of items
this next one may not necessarily apply
to you you may not want to do it and
that's totally okay
but i just want you to be aware of it
because i didn't know i got rid of all
the scented lotions and perfumes and
this one kind of hurt me it was the bath
and bodywork solutions because i got
great deals i mean you have to get the
deal right
so i had like 10 of these bottles that i
never even used
but i found out that these are harmful
and can actually cause cancer
because they have chemicals called
endocrine disruptors
so i tossed all those kinds of lotions
and i now only use coconut oil as lotion
and if i ever want a perfume then i use
essential oils if you're interested in
ridding your home of toxic chemicals
then perhaps i can do a video solely on
that because there's a lot to be said
about them and a lot of chemicals
that we aren't very aware of but i do
have a video on non-toxic personal care
swaps if you're interested
it's not very detailed i should have
done a better job it was one of my first
videos but there is some good
information in there for you
the next area of the home is not
necessarily an area but rather a group
of items and that is
items that require changing batteries
out or replacing the items frequently so
why do i even mention this in the first
place
because our lives are already hectic
enough to have to worry about little
details such as darn i can't use this
because i forgot to buy batteries or i
have to go to the store and get more
little things like that not only take up
our time but they're adding extra
expenses frequently
one example for us that frequently
caused an annoyance was that we had
purchased
wireless cameras and we knew upfront
that we were gonna have to replace
batteries on them but
at the time it seemed like a good idea
we were constantly having to replace
batteries about like
every two months and it was just getting
really annoying have to go to the store
just to buy the batteries
so we ended up finding a rechargeable
option for these things so now we don't
have to buy them
my suggestion would be that if you have
items that are like high dollar
that you don't want to necessarily get
rid of then try to find a replaceable
option or replaceable batteries for them
but if you can eliminate these items
altogether because they're just causing
more nuisance and hassle for you
so because there are numerous items that
can fall under this category i'm
actually planning on making a
separate video to talk about items that
you may have around the home that have a
reusable option for
not only can this save you money but it
can save you time as well so stick
around for that one
but for now let's head to the toy room
it might get a little loud in there
this is my kids toy collection minus a
few books or puzzles that i rotate out
and then maybe a couple odds and ends
scattered throughout the house
but i consider them very fortunate to
have all these toys for those of you who
are parents
oh boy you know how fun it is to pick up
toys constantly and then five minutes
later they're scattered all throughout
the floor again
i think this is why the meme i hope you
step on the lego came out
because those things hurt i grew up poor
i grew up in the middle of a desert but
yet i never lacked
toys to play kitchen for example i used
leaves
as my plates and mud as the taco meat i
used rocks to make houses and roads i
didn't need legos heck i didn't even
know they existed
i also remember making a dollhouse out
of an old box
the point that i'm trying to make here
is that because i didn't already have
the toys that did the work for me
i was able to imagine and create things
on my own
i think that when we load our kids with
flashy toys and gadgets we rob them of
their imagination to create these
experiences for themselves
and not only that but we're teaching
them at a young age that consumerism is
what will make them happy
so my tips for tackling kids toys are
these if your kids are young
go through the toys when they're not
around because even if that toy has been
in the corner of the room for months
they will want it only because you
picked it up if your kids are older go
through it with them
let them pick the favorites that they
want to keep and also have a
conversation with them
about sharing the toys that they will no
longer be using by donating them to
other children
this can be really difficult for them
especially if they're not used to it but
it can help them stretch their
decluttering muscle
and learn how to practice more
minimalism in their own life
to learn how to give and focus on giving
rather than receiving
it can also help them learn how to
practice more gratitude by learning how
to be happy with less
and for the toys that you do keep try to
keep open-ended toys that let them use
their imagination without flashy buttons
lights and sounds
for example i had a random cloth from a
dress that i had sewn and my daughter
loves this thing she uses it to wrap
gifts that she gives to us
she uses it as a scarf as a cover as a
cape
in many different ways so this would be
an example of an open-ended toy
if they have lots of toys with batteries
consider removing those not only does it
remove
them from having that constant attention
grabber
but it also prevents you from having to
go buy batteries because how annoying
and the last tip that i have for this
area is to consider letting your friends
and family know that you would like for
them to avoid purchasing gifts for your
kids
and if you have family members or
friends that would do it anyway
because i have some of those myself also
have a list of wish list toys for
example for me
that would be wooden toys or educational
activities
because someday i do want to homeschool
there are of course
many more ways to simplify your home so
if you have any suggestions
please leave them in the comments and if
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so that you
won't miss out on my weekly videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to see you in the next one